Speaker 1: I have a great clip today of Pete
Buttigieg just crushing a mayonnaise brained
Fox News host who tries to do the same old
thing to Mayor Pete, who is now Secretary
of Transportation Pete Buttigieg.
So here's the kind of setup.
As many of you know or may have heard of,
Supreme Court Justice Brett Kavanaugh recently
had to deal with protesters at a restaurant.
And in the aftermath of this and Brett Kavanaugh
leaving through the back door, people started
talking about the right to have dinner at
restaurants and the right to privacy and all
of these crazy things in the context of what's
happening with abortion laws and the fact
that there have been protests at abortion
clinics, family planning clinics that that
provide abortion services for so long, and
they are intimidatory and predatory against
women who just want to go and get procedures
done there.
It's a medical location.
The contrast is unbelievable, truly.
And in the midst of this, a Pete Budda judge's
husband put out a tweet talking about, oh,
you know, right to privacy and kind of poking
fun at the absurdity and the double standard
of these right wingers.
So Mayor Pete goes on Fox News and the host
tries to pull the whole is it appropriate
for the husband of it you know level up and
Pete booted judge puts on a clinic truly excellent.
We've talked about his skills before.
It's hard to find a time where he goes on
Fox News and doesn't humiliate the host and
the entire apparatus of Fox News.
So let's just jump into it and we'll talk
about it as it as we watch it.
Speaker 4: Your husband tweeted after Justice
Brett Kavanaugh left a Washington restaurant
due to protesters.
The tweet reads.
Sounds like he just wanted some privacy to
make his own dining decisions.
Is that appropriate, sir?
Look, when public officials go into public
life, we should expect two things.
One are you should always be free from violence,
harassment and intimidation.
And two, you're never going to be free from
criticism or peaceful protest, people exercising
their First Amendment rights.
And that's what happened in this case.
Remember, the justice never even came into
contact with these protesters.
That reportedly didn't.
Speaker 1: That's an important thing he did.
He became aware that they were out front and
he left through the back door.
Speaker 4: See or hear them.
And these protesters are upset because a right,
an important right that the majority of Americans
support was taken away by not only the right
to choose, by the way, but but this justice
was part of the process of stripping away
the right to privacy.
As long as I've been alive, settled by this
law in the United States and.
Speaker 1: Listen to the fox host trying to
interject.
Speaker 4: Has been that the constitution
protected a right to privacy and that has
now been thrown out the window by justices,
including Justice Kavanaugh, who, as I recall,
swore up and down in front of God and everyone,
including the United States Congress, that
they were going to leave settled case law
alone.
So, yes, people are upset.
They're going to exercise their First Amendment
rights.
And as long as that's peaceful, that's protected.
Compare that, for example, to the reality
that as a country right now, we're reckoning
with the fact that a mob summoned by the former
president.
Right.
Well, let me follow his lead.
Speaker 1: Don't make that.
Don't go into that direction, please.
Speaker 4: I just says capital for the purpose
of overthrowing the election and very nearly
succeeded in preventing the peaceful transfer
of power.
But I think common sense can tell the difference.
But as a high profile public figure, sir.
Speaker 1: What's funny is Pete spent 90 seconds
explaining why the question is ridiculous.
And the host just basically repeats the question.
Speaker 4: Are you comfortable with protesters
protesting when you and your husband go to
dinner at a restaurant?
Protesting peacefully outside in a public
space?
Sure.
Look, I can't even tell you the number of
spaces, venues and scenarios where I've been
protested.
And the bottom line is this.
Any public figure should always, always be
free from violence, intimidation and harassment,
but should never be free from criticism or
people exercising their First Amendment rights.
Speaker 1: Pete Budda Judge is really, really
good at this.
And these are the types of things where these.
This plays well, you know, tens of millions
of views in the kind of online sphere, YouTube
and Twitter, etc..
But the bigger issue is lots of people are
never exposed to these types of confrontations.
Of the absurdity of the arguments they're
making.
It's okay to protest outside an abortion clinic
where women are making medical decisions and
receiving treatment and and grappling with
difficult decisions.
But Morton Steak House out front while Kavanaugh
is inside and doesn't even come into contact
with the protesters, were supposed to believe
that that is in some way unacceptable.
And with all of these these things, all of
the tone, policing and decorum, there are
major double standards.
We talked about one earlier on in the show.
Barack Obama was regularly criticized for
these little tiny, meaningless things.
Oh, he took off his suit jacket in the Oval
Office.
He wore a tan suit at a serious event.
He put his feet up on the desk at the White
House.
And Trump drops an F-bomb while attacking
his political opponents at his rally in Anchorage
over the weekend.
And it's not just that the crowd doesn't mind.
They cheer.
They celebrate the fact that Trump is swearing,
by their logic, very unbecoming of a former
president.
So a lot of people I know are saying, well,
David, what if this happened to you?
This has happened to me.
I mean, there have been people at events that
I've done who were in the room, and this was
a while ago.
And they stood up and they they tried to kind
of take over the event by asking these attack
sort of questions to the point where the organizers
said, Hey, guy, okay, that's good.
You've made your point.
We're now moving on.
At a restaurant, I believe it was last summer,
I told the story of an anti-Semitic confrontation.
And it was not someone coming up to me and
saying, hey, you know, David, I know your
show and I disagree with you about your take
on the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
And I'd love to talk to you about my perspective
that that would be fine.
Let me have my dinner and then we can talk
about that.
No, it was a screaming imperialist Jew bastard
at me from across the room while I'm with
my friends having dinner and.
Hey, you know what?
It's not comfortable.
But what is the argument that it's illegal?
Or what exactly is it that they are saying?
Oh, well, it's the appropriateness of the
husband of the secretary of transportation
supporting protesters who Kavanaugh never
even came into court.
Come on, guys, give me a break.
And so Pete doing an excellent job.
He would be.
Again, we're I'm talking here about optics
and skill.
He would be a very reasonable presidential
candidate now more well-known than he was
last time around.
I find him very interesting, highly skilled,
and he did an excellent job there.